Good morning.
Uh,
today's stop the keys
Weber's a theory of legal,
rational authority and his
theory of bureaucracy. Uh,
uh,
this is one of those questions,
those topics. Faber is probably
the best known for. Uh,
it's also that they're a complicated
issue when we are saying legal rational
authority be briefly referred to the rule,
the rule of law.
And we tend to associate in our mind
that the rule of law a bit liberal market
economies and the liberal democracies,
well they bear has a very
complex argument about this.
Um,
uh,
in the League or National Authority is
the kind of system of authority which is
predictable.
Uh,
because there is an observable
law. Everybody's, uh,
a subordinated to which
in fact has the, uh, most,
uh, uh, um, uh,
the clearest elective affinity
with a market economy. Um,
nevertheless, uh, um, uh, as video see,
he will argue that which is very counter
intuitive that a bureau stype of Frigo
National Authority is bureaucracy.
And this is usually what we don't have
in our mind when we are thinking about,
uh, uh, uh, a market economy
that it is bureaucratic.
So, um, uh,
we have to deal with Weber's interesting
claim that the purest type of legal
rational authority,
which goes together with and Monica
capitalistic economy is actually
bureaucracy.
Um,
it's also interesting that vapor does
not make an assumption that I'm a
bureaucracy legal rationale authority
or capitalism necesarrily goes together
with democracy.
How democracy fits into the picture
is a rather problematic for him.
Of course, we have to appreciate that
in Weber's when vapor was writing,
um,
uh,
about these issues somewhere
between a 1914 or 1920,
uh, um, I mean,
virtually none of the countries in
the world where liberal democracies on
universal suffrage and, um, uh,
the political systems of the world
changed so much in the last hundred years.
But he problematizes does relationship
and it's actually quite useful.
So this is, uh, uh, the, um, uh, uh,
guideline for today's lecture.
Again, I strived with, uh, uh,
the definition of the ideal type,
the purest type of legal
rational authority.
And then I tried to dig into these,
a unusual but very influential Avebury
and argument that bureaucracy in fact is
the purest Stipe, a fleet,
rational national authority.
And then Ivo look at various kind of,
uh,
limitations of the exercise
of bureaucratical authority.
One is called the reality. The other
is functional division of Labor that I,
the separation of various
branches of government,
which is a limitation on
bureaucracy and representation.
Democracy as a limitation on government.
So you can see that he sees,
um, attention, right between democracy,
bureaucracy, legal, rational authority,
and capitalists.
They do not go as easily together as
usually we Americans tend to think about
this. And then a couple
of ideas about, uh,
uh, his, uh, his view about, uh, uh, uh,
democracies.
Okay.
So let me start with
what is the pure type,
um, uh, for, uh, illegal
rational authority. And, uh,
there are really two issues. We
have to very briefly talk about, um,
that are different ways how laws
and norms can be established.
You already beginning to feel
our way into the problem.
Whether the rule of law and democracy
are identical order, you know,
it can be democratic or does not
have to be that democracy democratic.
Um, and, uh, uh, then the question is, uh,
who obeys a wallet and home
on the legal authority.
Um, so, um, uh, and a, a bit about, uh,
I leave that Asher authorities. So
the, uh, the argument years rather,
there are various ways, um, how, uh, uh,
laws or norms can be established. Uh, um,
uh, and, uh, well he said, you know, uh,
legal or quality or rest on the
acceptance of the following guy ideas,
right? Well, the norms,
he said they can be
established by agreement.
That's what we usually think when we
think about rule of law or by imposition.
It can be imposed on people,
right?
And it can happen on the
ground of expediency.
And it can happen because
these are the most useful laws.
And therefore the either agreed
that this is what we want to obey,
or there is an authority
which we impose on us.
Or it can be based on value.
Rationality may not be that
expedient may not be necessary,
immediately useful,
but on the basis of shared values or the
values of those who impose those laws,
and we tend to believe it.
Uh, uh, uh, reveal, uh,
this is the way how it will be
established. And then, you know,
of course,
the legal system,
it has to be a somewhat
consistent, uh, uh, right? Uh,
this is important for the predictability
of the system and it has to be
intentionally established,
right? Is Not coming, uh,
uh, or from, uh, uh, um, accident,
but intentionally established. But the
major point, what I wanted to make right,
that a legal, rational authority,
uh, in Weber's view, um,
can be actually an
authoritarian system. Uh, uh,
let's say, uh, uh,
chiller under Pinochet the later
times after he established,
so consolidated his power earlier
on it was a tire and Nicole, ooo,
but later on, you know,
Pinochet establish the, uh,
Ellie got rational order though it
was not democratic at all, right?
It was operating a weak legal system.
We tried,
he imposed on people. And you
know, in history we have a,
uh, a number of instances.
Then we can say, you know,
this country is a country
of law and law and order.
Uh, we know what the laws are. Uh,
we actually think the
laws are not unreasonable.
But it was imposed by some power upon us.
Now the next question is,
uh, who obeys a home and, well,
I don't want to develop on this along.
This is quite clear.
You already are familiar with this.
What is important?
Add the person who is in
authority, we issues orders, uh,
um, um, um,
is himself subject to an impersonal order.
So we are all subject to the same order.
This is the essence of Frigo
rational authority. Um, uh,
um, uh, uh, at least in the IDR type,
right? Uh, we, we know the
exceptions to this. Uh, uh, you know,
that will scorn if for instance,
in Italy, Italy really are illegal.
National Authority for a long time managed
a right to pass a legislation which
enabled him to escape prosecution.
Though he's probably involved a
number of criminal activities,
but somehow he managed to
escape criminal prosecution. Uh,
but that's the exception.
The rule is right that even
the person who is, uh, uh,
highest in charge is subject to the same
mortality and it has to obey the law.
Uh, and this is again, very obvious.
We already covered this. A the opposite,
the mirror image of it, right. Uh,
the members of the society,
uh, over or obedience, uh,
uh, uh, not to the superior,
not as an individual,
but to an impersonal order to,
to the law as such.
That should be quite obvious now. Um, uh,
so what are the major characteristic
of a system which is based on legal,
rational order?
That is a continuous rule bound conduct?
Uh, it's again, you know,
I think it does not a
call for too much, uh, uh,
clarification. Uh, it is continuous.
The same rules, the rules,
uh,
change slowly and with great deal of
difficulties as we see how congress is
struggling to pass a law about
how secure that for him, you know,
it takes months or years before an
important let new piece of legislation,
yes, into a place and usually
new pieces of legislations,
uh, in legal action or authority.
Our grandfather, right.
If you pass a new law,
you change the rules of the game.
You're usually grandfather them.
Those who entered the game before the
new law are still under the rule of the
old law. But you do that
at the universities all the
time, right? If for instance,
a degree requirements do change
in our university almost overs,
this degree requirements are these,
uh,
these new legislation is
grandfather are, you know, the, the,
the terminology,
right?
It will not apply to people
who are already in the program.
It feels only applied to people
who are entering the program or at,
or, you know, one way of grandfathering,
get that v if people are choice,
you know,
if you want to operate under the new
order or you can opt for the new oral, uh,
or if you want to stay under the old rule,
you can stay on the old rule,
only do four dome.
Those are the new rule binding
who are entering the system now.
So that's very important, right? That
is continuous and uh, and uh, um,
and roll band. And he's also said
in Ligo rational authority, uh,
there must be a very clear
separation of stress of competence,
right? Uh, who is, uh, uh,
competent to carry out what, uh,
and then you can have as a,
uh,
figured out how you will navigate in
that ego rational order. Uvl Be told,
well, this is not my table
or you go somewhere else.
So you go and you ask
something, um, from, uh,
the director of undergraduate studies
and the director of undergraduate studies
might say, go and see the dean of
your residential college. Right?
Because that is this fair of
competence of the residential college.
That's the way how legal
rational or ESC pose to operate.
And the same, you know, occasionally
the dean of college will say they are,
you have to see, um, uh,
your sociology professor or
your economics professor, right?
You want to get transfer credit,
for instance, for a summer course.
And then the dean of college,
they all said, you know,
it is the department be political
science or economics or anthropology.
They will be able to tell whether this is,
can be accepted as a, uh, uh,
an economic scores at year. Right. Um, um,
and this also implies that that is over
as a hierarchy and the right to have
appeal. This is, again, you are very
familiar with, you know, exactly. Uh,
if, uh, uh, you get a grade from
your discussion section leader,
you can appeal to the, to
the professor to say, well,
I don't think it's a fairly not grade.
I deserve a better grade, you know, uh,
and my section leader
and made an an error.
And if you are unhappy with
the response of the professor,
you go to the chair of the
department and at the old,
the cello and they had is a
whole hierarchy of Aptio. Right?
But you can try to correct
what you think is, uh, uh,
are not right. So I think it's
extremely important that you know, you,
you know exactly what is the chain
of appeal and how far you can go up,
but was surely there is also
some specialized straining, uh,
which is, uh, uh,
expected for people to do,
occupies certain positions.
Uh, so, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, discussion of section
leaders viewed all of us be, um,
at least graduate
students. Uh, um, uh, uh,
usually hell people can teach their
own course once they were past,
uh, um, uh, uh, they
had, uh, a phd students,
but all of over they have
is a dissertation to finish
or they must have that phd
and I, so that is a specialized
training and that's history, uh,
to perform certain functions
as such. Um, and that's,
uh,
an interesting and very complex idea here.
Either the staff has to be separated
from the ownership of means of production
and administration. And this
is even more important for, uh,
for, for Weber's argument being
separated, you know, it's, uh,
not, not that easy to penetrate what
he exactly wants to saving this.
What does it mean that you do not
own the means of administration?
It basically means that the source
of rules and laws are outside off the
administrators. As such, if you want
to have any change in the rules,
then must be some procedure
which is beyond the person
who is administering that
rules. How the rules can be changed,
right. And this, in order to, you have,
could prevent, uh, um, uh,
unpredictability in the system.
And that's why, you know, rules
change all the time. Uh, but, uh, the,
the, the fundamental principle is that
these rules should not be allowed to be
changed, uh, um,
by the person who administers
the writer though those rules.
Um, uh, so, uh, you know,
just to give a very
trivial example, once, uh,
you got your syllabus and the
course requirement, then, uh,
you know what kind of from
assignments you have to, uh,
uh,
they'll liver during the course in
order to get credit in this course,
then a welder Verking
out these rules, uh, uh,
professor plays a role. Uh, but you know,
we have to be get approved by the
courses and curriculum committee and then
innovative. We are bound by
those rules. So on Dovey,
I could not announce you today.
Well,
I changed my mind and that
will be an unseen, you know,
final examination.
Maryville have,
you will have to get a final examination,
right?
And Uv or not know what
questions I will ask him.
I can ask any question for the whole
course, right. If I would change, right.
These, uh, these rules right now,
uh, you have or would have app,
I'm sure appeal, you know, against
me, my, against my decision, right?
I'm bound Baru, so that, that means that
I don't own the means of administration,
right? I am, I am administering,
right? Uh, what is, uh, in, in,
in the syllabus that is a little
Levy, right? Occasionally,
I can give you an extension,
for instance, uh, uh, uh,
if you come to me, I mean,
therefore, it's, uh, uh, you know,
that is a little flexibility in the
system, but fundamentally, you know,
the course should be taught as,
as it is, uh, uh, in the syllabus.
And the requirement should be like
it is in the syllabus. That's what,
what it means, right? That you do not
own a ride. The means of administration,
unlike in traditional authority where
a feudal lord does have a dog's own,
appropriated some means of
administration from, uh, the,
the monarch and, uh, you know,
uh, British or the French,
uh, of high aristocracy,
uh, could, uh, make rules,
um, and not implemented those,
but would make rules as well.
The unique feature of modern, uh, uh,
legal rational authority is that
this becomes an impersonal process,
uh, by which is, uh, uh, uh, uh, not done.
There is a separation between those
who implement the rules and there's a
separate procedure.
How the rules are being established.
Is that reasonably clear about
ownership of means of administration?
Means has not appointed out is a
very, very, very an idea, right?
For four Mark Strad, the whole
issue is the means of, uh, uh,
ownership of means software
production for vapor.
This is everything about the
administrations, uh, um, the,
uh, the means of administration. Okay.
Now we come to this very interesting way,
very and theory of the bureaucracy,
very interesting guy, very controversial
in many ways. Very counter intuitive.
Uh, you may say it is false.
Uh, uh, well, uh, see,
uh, and uh, that is a nice stop
before discussion sections. Um,
and, uh, Ivr, this is what I veal
will through a number of issues.
What is a bureaucracy, a
vapor and makes these, uh, uh,
quite incredible claim.
But first,
a UVL completely reject that the most
efficient organization is the bureaucracy.
Right? That's exactly the opposite
of what you think. You know,
when something is very
inefficient, then you say, well,
this is so bureaucratic,
right?
They were never that US claims that
the most efficient organization is
bureaucracy. Then, you know,
the question is how is
bureaucracy related to capitalism?
And socialism is really capitalism,
a bureaucratic organization,
but is the relationship between capitalist
market, economy and bureaucracy,
but are the consequences of bureaucracy
and also then some contradiction of
bureaucratic position.
Now let's just quickly rush through
a for what are the characteristics,
um, Afa and bureaucracy. Now he said, ah,
the purest stype of legal authority.
This is, as I said, counter intuitive,
is that one dish employs a bureau
Katich administers if staff,
and, uh, well, uh,
what are the characteristics of the
staff in order to qualify to be due to
bureaucracy? They all, they
have to be personally three.
So it cannot be clients,
writer of a mentor, right? Uh,
there are legally free individuals that
makes it so different from a traditional
organization.
That's why a family is not a bureaucratic
organization because you are not, uh,
uh, uh, there are by
choice. Right? Um, uh,
and then,
and bureaucracy is organized into a
hierarchy of offices is something which
basically we already covered.
Um,
under the offices are a
field by a free contract.
Um, and, uh, in this contractor,
what your qualification is,
that's what we call that meritocracy.
People do have as it grows to a certain
degree and that degree qualifies them to
be incumbents have a certain office
and the receiver a fixed salary that's,
uh, uh, uh, it's not quite a
bureaucratic organization. Um,
if you're working for a
commission, right? Uh,
you are really in a
bureaucratic organization when
you sign a contract and you
know exactly what you are fringe benefits
will be and what your annual salary
will be, will be. Uh, uh,
typically the office is,
uh,
is the sole occupation of the
incumbents and it constitutes a career.
This is also very important,
again,
very different from a traditional
organization where people could,
uh,
actually we incumbents have a number
of positions and could draw in fact,
even incomes from a number of position.
In a pure bureaucratic organization,
uh,
you really can't have only, um, uh,
a single occupation. Um, uh,
uh, you know, if, uh, uh,
for instance, uh, uh,
somebody is appointed, uh, uh,
with tenure to Yale and,
uh,
is coming from another institution will
have to resign from his or her tenure at
the other institution.
If you are employed by year,
you can be only a year employee.
You cannot hold the multiple
jobs at the same time. Uh,
and uh, and it constitutes a courier and
the courier and means that is a letter.
You have some sense,
you know,
how you will progress in these
bureaucratic hierarchy. Uh,
again, the universities are classic
raw bureaucracies. You know,
that you entered as an
assistant professor,
then you are seven to nine years
depending on the institution of is south
tenure.
Then you are being promoted to tenure.
Then you expect that one point of time
to become a full professor, blah, blah,
blah. Right? I, this is what it meant.
It is a career and in many bureaucratic
organization, even in the business world,
right? You'll have a sense, you know,
how you progress, uh, in a law firm,
right? Uh, if you entered a
law firm, right? Uh, you have,
you have a pretty clear idea that
it's actually very similar to the
universities.
Usually for seven years you are working
for the law firm and that's when you can
be gone right. At partner in the law firm.
Right. And, um, the, the crowd, you know,
so you, you, you, you have a sense
how your carrier veal unfold.
Um, uh, well,
uh, this is something we order
the kind of, uh, um, uh, uh, uh,
cover dry that you are separated
from the means of administration,
uh,
because you are subjected to this
zipline and control now comes the very
controversial idea.
And what do we have to talk about this,
uh, Weber's claim, you know,
which is against very much
against common sense, uh,
that, uh, uh,
the purely bureaucratic type
of administration he was
capable of attaining the
highest degree of efficiency. Uh, uh,
well,
uh,
led me on the other hand from the citation
on the line and important point here,
and this is a, you know,
uh, uh, of course we were,
was talking about a very specific
type of organization, you know,
bureaucracies which are relatively
speaking historically quite efficient,
slide the plush and type of bureaucracy.
But here,
here he emphasizes,
and this is,
these are two very important words
from the technical point of view,
right? The bureaucracy from the technical
point of view is the most efficient
organization.
It does not necessarily means that it
does achieve the highest valve fail for
people who are seeking to not navigate
in a bureaucratic organization,
but technically speaking, it
is the most efficient. Why?
Because it has a very high
degree of predictability. I mean,
this predictability might suggest that
it will take you a long time to get
through of that bloody Red Day, right?
What the bureaucracy was, is on you,
but you know exactly the red tape
and you know, if you are stuck,
you know how to try to appeal and
to get the process moving. So,
and therefore the crucial issue.
He said by the bureaucracy is so efficient
because it is technically competent
now. And it is, it is predictable.
And, uh, this is what makes it,
uh, actually, uh, so
to fit so well with the, uh, uh, uh, uh,
a Marquette, uh, uh, well he said,
what else? If, if it is not bureaucracy,
how can you advise,
organize an organization if it is
not done bureaucratically than it is
dilettantism. Right? Uh, um, uh,
and you may want to think about this
now. Uh, uh,
here comes the question about how
does a bureaucracy and capitalism are,
uh, fits into, um, uh,
and now he makes a very intriguing,
very provocative claim.
I think it is very deep and
deserves your attention.
He said the primary source of
superiority in a administration,
uh, life's in technical
knowledge. Uh, right. Uh,
bureaucracy is domination
through knowledge.
Now, a very provocative,
very important claim, right?
Bureaucracy is right.
The par exsalonce medical
cratic organization, right?
That people who are issuing command
artist showing command did the assumptions
that they are the most competent
people to carry this out. Well,
whether this is the case
or not, I, I, you know,
you remember Vba is all of us operating
with idea of taps or pure types.
The concrete cases may be
a different from it. Uh,
you may have people who are not competent,
uh,
to exercise the authority,
what they do exercise.
But I think it is important that you
have the idea of tie because then you can
be upset and you say, these bloody
bastard, right? It is incompetent,
cannot do their job and then
you can appeal and to say,
why don't you remove this person because
this person does not know about his or
her job is,
and actually such an appeal.
Very often it's consequential people.
Occasionally I removed that position
if that in competence is being
demonstrated.
Um,
when all this is very difficult with
the university because universities,
we have the system of
tenure, you know, um,
after I use a software for seven
years as an assistant professor,
you are promoted to tenure and then it
is very difficult to get you out of the
job.
But even at the university is possible
if you find out that I'm completely
incompetent, right? You'll document
that I am incompetent, right?
That I'm just misinterpreting
all the orders you had here. Um,
and then you can appeal right to the
university and you can say that I really
should be removed. I, you know, my, uh,
tenure should be involved and
if I found to be incompetent,
I will lose my job about the
only way to do it. Yeah. Look,
prove my competence.
Actually University is very rarely do
it because a very painful exercise,
but because they are bureaucracies,
their is right.
The rule that it can happen and
it should happen in these cases.
And then he said, well, from
this point of view material,
it does not matter whether
an economy's organized as a,
um,
a capitalistic economy based on private
ownership or whether it is organized as
a socialist economy based on public
ownership. Right. And in fact,
now he goes even further and
it's very interesting what he's,
he got to say here in the, um, uh,
he's writing the some that in 1919,
1920 a the Soviet Union already exists,
Russia or the exists that
is already as society,
which costs itself Socialist,
which eliminated private ownership and
he said the hell socialism of would
require a still higher degree of former
bureau categorization then capitalism.
That's a very interesting idea though.
Antio now he's suggested, right that uh,
the bureaucratic organization is
the best bit free market economy.
Now he said, actually socialism,
you be even more bureaucratic.
And then I think what comes very,
it's a very intriguing idea.
And he said,
but the big problem with socialism is
that there will be a big conflict here
between,
uh,
the former rationality and
substantive rationality,
but the bureaucracy carries out
and you'll know by now, right?
Or do you have at least a hunch,
but he's getting get between
formal and substantive rationality,
right?
Former nationality is that you are simply
implementing the rules of the game.
Um,
uh,
substantive rationality is you are
actually concerned with develop fair,
the substantive goals of the action.
And he said,
well if you have a publicly owned
economies, centrally planned economy,
then the central planners make
substantive decisions about the economy.
They decide for instance,
their government or taxpayer money
should go off. We'll go to you know,
which branches of the
economy should be investment.
We're going to write in
a capitalist economy.
Governments you typically cannot do that,
right? They said the rules of the game,
well the best,
you know,
they manage interest rates and you know
they may be able to manage the currency
exchange rate but they cannot allocate
resources across the economy or if they
do, uh, then people there save, we
are on the road to socialism, right?
To the extent substantive
rationality is involved, but he said,
well if it is socialism, that
will be this big tension, right?
You cannot be at the same time for money,
rational and substantively rational.
You either consider that content of your
decisions or you are concerned simply
the the procedures of the decision.
If you are concerned with the
procedure that is former rationality,
if you are concerned with the content
that is substantive rationality.
Let me just give you one example
about the legal system. Uh,
indeed in Communist societies, uh, uh,
and probably to some extent
even China today, uh, uh,
too much less so than it was
at say 30 or 40 years ago.
Uh, well, uh, when justice
is being served by the court,
the court is not blind to who of people
who are being accused of committing some
crime is um, uh, uh, the communist,
the legal system called itself
a class law that in fact,
the purpose of the legal system
is not to be blind right now.
Who committed the crime.
The purpose of the legal system is that
was the kind of legitimacy see claim and
their communism to defend the interest
of the working class. Um, right.
And therefore that was,
uh,
specifically illegal system based on
substantive rationality right now,
uh, um, uh, capitol,
this legal system then to be procedurally
right rationale is the former,
the rationality in principle.
It doesn't matter who the person is.
Then you are serving a justice.
This is again the ideal,
right? In concrete cases actually, um, uh,
uh,
judges might consider
some sort of substantive
characteristics of the person who
is on trial and not simply
to implement the law, uh,
may consider as mitigating circumstances,
right?
For instance,
when they are passing the law.
And of course there are other reasons
how actually substantive considerations
entered the game. You know,
um, if you are white and rich,
you can hire a better defense lawyer
and your chances to get off the horse.
Basically,
we've seen the same rules are veterans.
So substantive considerations centered
the theme, but that's the exception.
That's not supposed to happen. The are
angry when it, this is happens, right?
We want to have a faceless legal system,
right?
A justice is blind,
These blindness of justice
means radices simply,
procedurally just right and
not substantively so. Right?
This is why justice is shown.
We had blind eyes.
Now what are the consequences
of bureaucratic position? Uh,
here are some of them.
He said that it is a tendency of leveling
of interests since everybody's in
principle equal before the law.
And therefore interest will be level.
You are not supposed to take the
intellect down people's position in it.
Um,
well there is a tendency Medico
cratic tendency that people,
uh,
higher up feel have higher levels of
training or more training guest such,
uh, and uh, uh, the,
this is again, you know,
justice is blind. Uh,
uh, what is important is,
uh,
that uh,
the essence of a bureaucracy has to be
a formalistic impersonality a Sienna era
at studio, uh, this out hatred,
then passion, right? Uh,
this is why occasionally you are kind of
upset when you are confronted with the
bureaucracy. You have a
special problem, you know,
and then to bureaucracy tends to be
insensitive to your special problem,
right? Uh, uh, van it
is audio bureaucracy,
right? Uh, you can't say, you know,
I just had a fight with my,
uh, uh, [inaudible] and this
is my, I cannot take the test.
Well, see, you're not either a studio.
I mean, ah, in our yard, bureaucratic,
a discussion leader or professor
of you say, too bad, uh, you know,
this is your person or business.
The test is right now, uh,
you take it or leave it. Well, I mean, uh,
APP usually not that stupid bureaucrats,
but that's the spirit of bureaucracy,
right? This, our teacher, that passion,
that also means that you are
not motivated by, um, uh, uh,
various or no,
uh, uh, uh,
feelings. You know, you
don't differentiate.
This is a person I like and then I give
preferences Rodesh light and therefore
diva, uh, adverse grade. Oh, right.
That are and number of contradictions
of bureaucracy. Uh, uh,
if is,
uh,
ah, ah, AH,
Betty formalistic. Yeah. Uh, um,
and he said that is also
another interesting tendency
do it is formalistic and
it's supposed to go
by, uh, at the, um, uh,
simply by the rule arose occasionally
not only under socialism,
in all systems, the bureaucracy
then to have, uh, uh,
some sensitivity to substantive
rationality to the welfare
of the people who are
under, uh, the bureaucracy.
And then it can turn into a
client that is stick system.
The bureaucracy can,
can have these, uh, uh,
these standards can think about that
fared bureaucracies, right? Miss,
you do have a great deal
of client that is Steve.
Dan Dance is built into them well,
and that are these various limitations
of bureaucratical authority.
Vaughn is collegiality,
a division of powers and representation.
Well,
um,
I don't want to dwell too long
on the notion of collegiality.
Collegiality says, really
grows out of, um, uh,
uh,
Watch v you as a,
uh, uh, um, uh, um, uh, um,
as a,
okay.
The fashion all or groups or
professional or organizations.
So, um, that are different
ways how collegiality, uh,
can, can operate, uh, uh, one, uh, they,
uh,
that that means that you are interacting
with other people in the same, uh,
organization on the basis of collegiality.
Uh,
you can get a good sense
of these collegiality,
collegiality, for instance. Uh, uh,
it's very important in the
medical profession. Um,
if you go to a doctor
for a second opinion, uh,
this doctor is really not supposed
to say that his or her colleague,
the other doctor, uh, uh, video,
the school data and he gave
you the wrong diagnosis or,
or the or the wrong territory, right? Uh,
collegiality means that you stick
together rather the profession, uh,
sticks together. Um, uh,
that is a very strong
sense of collegiality among
lawyers or at least supposed
to be. The attic of legal profession
is very much collegiality.
And it is also, um, uh,
uh, incidentally in, in,
in the universities.
I mean,
okay.
Faculty is not supposed to bad mouth
each other, right? They, uh, uh,
certainly towards students they have
to show that they have a collegial
relationship with each other. Mutual
respect, balance them together. Uh,
occasionally that is a,
what he calls me talk all the reality.
The collegiality does,
Does Give Vico right?
To certain people to do
run this organization.
A single person can
veto a decision. Uh, uh,
such a, again, very typical
in universities, uh, um, uh,
vanee comes for instance,
to decision whether somebody's view will
be granted a permanent position in a
university. So called
tenure. That is actually,
I'm the president of the university
usually has a veto right?
And can veto no matter
that all, uh, bodies, uh,
approved that the president
usually have a vitro, right.
Can veto that to decision.
It uses it very rarely,
but occasionally it does use a,
it's a veto or, right. Uh, so, uh,
in, in even in a collegiality,
organized, uh, uh, uh,
a bureaucracy that is these,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
individually [inaudible] score,
the GLT usually operates through
different committees and advisory boards.
Yeah.
Uh, uh, uh, uh,
I mean,
collegiality,
you surely is emerging in a situation
where you have a common trade or a common
profession.
That's when a group is being
organized as a collegial bureaucracy.
And as such, um, and, uh, uh, uh,
many or few Vlm Dapa and
professions in the bitch,
uh, UVL have, uh, uh, um, uh, uh, uh,
such a collegial, um, uh, uh, uh,
an environment as such a, um, uh,
okay. Uh, the other issuers,
which is also a limitation of the
functioning of the bureaucracy, right?
A collegiality man tried that though.
Uh,
the bureaucracy is supposed to be
blinded to individual differences.
It's not all of us because we have lawyer
off the stove was each other based on
our profession.
Lawyers,
solid legal to lawyers and doctors and
loyal to fellow doctors and professors.
So I have a degree of loyalty.
Um, now the other one is a, um,
uh, uh, uh, division
of, uh, off Bowers. Um,
uh, now there's division
off Bowers, uh, uh,
law, uh, and Montesquieu. And there
was silver was talking about the,
well, it's a function or system. Uh,
he cites Montesquieu about the
separation of power, um, uh,
uh, uh, uh, and, uh, uh, uh,
that,
uh,
creates some degree of unpredictability,
uh, in, in, in the system, but
necessarily, but creates some degree,
um, uh, for entree.
Addictability. Nevertheless, uh,
this is a very hard to prevent diarrhea
and he's so therefore it is good for the
economy by what he means
for the market economy.
And then comes the question of
representations and different forms of
representation. So, um,
well that are very, again, you know,
what representation can be democratic and,
but is not necessarily all
that bloody democratic. Uh,
uh, uh, in fact,
that is a possibility of that presentation
when the representation is happening
through some, had a
deterring means, uh, uh, uh,
u s you know,
in
the additional authority,
uh,
people who were born in Sudan position
like Montesquieu, he himself, uhW,
was supposed to represent
certain interest, um,
and have each is beyond the,
uh,
the personal interest of the person that
was supposed to represent the interest
of the whole estate.
The what it did for standing for um,
well it's also, or in modern times,
we do have our representation,
well,
representations can be selected by,
by rotation or, or lot, um, uh,
in ancient Greece this happened. Um, uh,
and that can be a limited,
uh, mandate. Um, uh,
they are not representing, uh, uh, uh,
necessarily the interest of their
constituency and they can be,
uh, can be recalled. Uh,
this was typical of a
communist bureaucracies, uh,
or that it can be what he calls free
representation is what people would
associate to democracy where the
representative is elected rather than,
uh, selected or appointed.
Um, and, uh, it bought,
it is also not bound by instructions,
is only obliged to express
his own conviction.
Uh, so, uh, this is what we have seen
in the congress happening, right?
The Demo Democrats, um, uh,
[inaudible], uh, uh, uh,
Republicans because those Democrats argue
that I'm not under party discipline,
right? I am acting out
of my conscience. Um,
now, uh, um, uh,
a couple of ideas about
three representation and how
it goes with a capitalistic
economy. Well, what is
cool short item, they were,
keeps coming back and back to this,
but is vital for a capitalistic economy,
has to be a cocktail ability
and reliability. Um, uh,
uh, um, and uh, uh, well in, uh,
early stages.
In fact,
there was property qualification who
could actually water and that was
implemented in order to make the system
more predictable for the property
classes.
There was a great deal of concern by the
bourgeoisie to give universal suffrage
because they felt then this view
would be unpredictable who via, um,
via the elections. Um, in fact, uh,
very often these were monarchs and
absolute monarchs who were pushing for
extension, right, of suffrage.
Because they wanted to use this
against their property, uh, was Razi.
That's against something
very counterintuitive,
but I think historically a
very accurate, uh, uh, uh, uh,
understanding Grad.
So one has to be very careful.
Uh,
what exactly the relationship with the
capitalist economic order and democracy
is. Uh, uh, uh, so,
uh,
Weber's fundamental argument is what
many people who do the history of
democratic movement feel, Agri others
view, disagree with him. Again,
a good subject for discussion.
Um,
a parliamentary fee representation
was the product, uh, between, uh,
struggles actually struggles between
monarchs and the bourgeoisie.
Um, uh, well,
I think I'll just leave this here or
probably gave us enough food for the
discussion.
Thank you.